we're going Raisinets no I think I'll be
pretty good at identifying things based
on their shapes I probably wouldn't eat
candy as much if they were all black and
white like a lot of my pleasure derives
from just looking at it I'm color blind
so a lot of it kind of make the colors
look the same there's no color reference
for me I'm probably not going to get
much right skittles or M&Ms it's the
side angle on the skittles which always
get me and I think these are skittles I
like oh no ma'am it ends because they
are smaller in diameter these look like
skittles to me
I love M&Ms I don't get diddles they're
pretty but this just look appetizing I'm
like it's skittles
they almost look like jellybeans for a
second but I think these are skittles
[Music]
all I was right boom right I was correct
Oh Snickers or Milky Way I can't see
much there's a lot of loving nougat
I think it's Snickers because it looks
like it has different colors and I know
and it might be like the peanuts man
it's been a while since I've had either
but I feel like Milky Way has a
marshmallow in between it and I'm not
seeing a marshmallow yeah I was right
correct
Snickers for the win dots or gumdrops I
don't know a dot sorry I didn't know
they were different damn what's it got
dots don't have the sugar but gumdrops
do and I can even see that in the
black-and-white photo these definitely
have sugar in them so gumdrops I'm right
yet again apparently I know my candy son
what's up I am as smart as I always
thought for most of them I was able to
distinguish what they were based on
their shape but color still plays a huge
role in how we perceive our reality and
our candies I don't want black and white
candy you know if they did make it
I would consume a lot less and have
fewer cavities
[Music]